Hello everybody and welcome to another
money making video. Today I'm going to
be showing you how I made about 950k
in only 10 minutes and that is buying
from a shop. From a shop. It's crazy.
I'll show you in a minute what it is,
but there isn't really any quest
requirements. Well, you do have to do
the giant dwarf. Beyond that, you will
need a bit of starting cash and by a bit
I mean quite a lot. People get pissed
off when I say a bit and I actually mean
30 mil.
But you don't have to have that much to
start with, but 950k that is fully
optimized. If you don't have as much
money, you'll make a bit less, but still
for 10 minutes of work not too bad. All
right, let's get started.
All right guys, so what we're going to
be doing today is we are going to be
buying from
the Keldagrim Stonemason shop. Now what
this is is a high-level construction
shop essentially. It has a three
different items that we're going to be
buying. The marble block, the gold leaf,
and the magic stone. And you can see
right here they have an extremely good
margin when sold back on the Grand
Exchange. Marble block has about an 8k
margin.
The gold leaf has a 5k margin. The magic
stone actually got about a 25k margin
when I did this.
So it's very lucrative and you will need
some starting cash like
the more the better, but you don't
necessarily need it cuz you could buy
the gold leaves or the marble blocks if
you have less.
So
that being said, before you attempt this
method, you 100% want to check the
prices that items are currently selling
at. They don't genuinely dip below
the price from the shop, but they can
and you want to be 100% sure that you'll
be profiting when you buy the items.
So we're using GE tracker for that and
the reason we are is because it has
access to the day graph which you can
give you the information as of the last
half an hour.
And we can see here we're selling them
for about 1 mil, so it's a 25k profit
right now.
But if we go back to the year, it's not
always like that. You can see sometimes
it dips down to 950. Sometimes it goes
way up to 1,100. Now this might be
before they got the shop guy added cuz
really levels out here. And that segues
me into my next point. It's kind of a
late Christmas present. I'm actually
going to be giving away a GE tracker
account. So if you are signed up to GE
tracker and have the free membership all
you have to do is post your GE tracker
username in the comment section. Make
sure you're subscribed to my YouTube
channel and toss a video like. And if
you get picked the winner we will
upgrade your account for 1 month to have
access to all the GE tracker features,
which include the day graph, money
making methods, as well as a bunch of
other cool features. All right guys,
let's actually jump into it now. All
right guys, so what we are going to be
doing and why this method is so easy is
because we're going to be buying from a
shop. Now this is a specialty shop
available only in Keldagrim
which is accessible
over by Relic. Let's see if we can get
over here. Too far and back
up.
All right, there we are.
Accessible right up here.
You're going to go through this passage
and it's going to bring you to
Keldagrim. Now the easiest way by far is
to go to that fairy ring which I'm going
to do right now. Otherwise
you can walk there, but uh
it's pretty far.
If you have completed the giant dwarf,
there is a shortcut from the Grand
Exchange
at the mine cart. Now I haven't actually
finished the quest. That being said, you
will need the requirements cuz the quest
needs to be started to actually access
Keldagrim. So you're going to come
through this cave here, through this
little crack, and then you're going to
talk to the boatman here.
And he'll bring you to Keldagrim. The
first time it's going to be a really
[__] long cutscene. But afterwards,
going to bring you right here. From
there, we are going to be going to this
shop down here. It's a little bit
southeast of the bank.
And what this shop sells is construction
supplies. Now they're high-level
construction supplies and they cost a
lot of money.
However, they often times and pretty
much all the time sell for much higher
on the Grand Exchange than they are sold
for in the shop.
You can get 20k, 25k margins on some of
the items. So
you will require a fair bit of starting
money to do this the most effectively,
but there are different price items for
different amounts of cash. We got 35 mil
here. We are borrowing from our flipping
account just for this. All right guys,
so we have
35 mil even. Now let's have a look at
the items here. So we have the magic
stone and the gold leaf as well as the
marble block are those that are worth
buying. So here are the costs. Now I'm
going to recommend you only buy one per
world cuz the cost goes up pretty
substantially every time you buy one.
Now the gold leaf is the most traded at
the current prices right now.
I have loaded up here on GE tracker.
Let's see. Start with the gold leaf. The
gold leaf seems to be selling for about
135. So there's about a 5k margin on the
gold leaf. This will probably only take
20 minutes to sell.
The marble block seems to be selling for
about 333
which will give us about a 8k margin on
the marble block.
And the magic stone definitely slows
sells the slowest by far.
But does have the largest margin selling
for about a mil. So that's 25k in the
magic stone.
Now this item does
trade a lot less. Probably take an hour
to sell each one of these.
That being said, for the for this video,
we're going to buy one of each.
And
while we have a timer open here just to
see how long it's actually going to take
us to buy these items. Really not going
to be that long.
We'll start the timer and yeah, let's
go.
All right, so we're just buying one per
world like I said and then hopping.
Now if you have let's say
10 mil or 5 mil, buying the uh
magic or the gold leaves are the most
efficient. Like you're getting the most
return on your investment cuz they only
cost well, 130k and you're getting 5k
back.
So they're definitely the most
efficient. I might actually consider not
even buying these marble blocks.
No, I think we will.
Um
the magic stones are by far the least
efficient cuz they cost almost a mil and
you're getting only 25k in profit.
That being said, since I do have enough
money and uh
we're kind of seeing how quickly we can
do this, this will probably be
the best item for me, but I would
recommend if you don't have that much
money to just do the gold leaves and
possibly the marble blocks because these
magic stones do take a while to sell as
well as cost a lot. All right guys,
we're down to about 5 minutes left and
we've spent definitely more than half
our cash.
Going to have to extremely advise you be
very careful when you're buying these
because if you hit the buy five as
opposed to the buy one you will lose
probably quite a bit money. So be very
mindful how you're clicking and try not
to
fall into a rhythm too much. You
definitely want to be focusing. You
don't You don't have to focus for like
10 minutes guys, so definitely pay
attention because
you could lose quite a bit if you are
not.
Also, if you don't really feel like
hopping worlds
they respond really quickly. So it's not
a huge deal if you just want to stay in
the same world. I'm just hopping for the
sake of just seeing how much I can
actually make in 10 minutes.
But it's not required. You can just stay
in the same world. They respond in about
5 seconds. I don't know. 10 seconds
maybe. Hard to tell, but it's not very
long. All right guys, that is it. We
only have 30k left and we have bought
all the supplies we could. It took us
about 8 minutes, so really not that long
at all.
Luckily we didn't accidentally buy five
of the magic stones cuz that would have
sucked.
So we'll go ahead and price check this.
That being said, the prices probably
won't be exact by any means. Okay, so
we'll go ahead and price check this. We
start with 35 mil and then now we have
35 686
approximately. The OSBuddy graph is
totally wrong for some reason.
Now this isn't very accurate. We'll go
ahead and go back to the Grand Exchange
and see how much we can actually sell it
for. All right guys, so we're at the
Grand Exchange and now before you sell
them and more importantly probably
before you buy these, it's important to
check the price for what they're selling
for. Now they almost never drop down
below their buy price. You can see here
even if we go back this for the the gold
leaf. Even if we go back to the year,
the lowest it would have was 131 and
only briefly. Almost always it's roughly
around
uh
the buy price from the shop. So it's not
a huge risk assuming you only buy one.
That being said, you definitely want to
check on the sell price. So right now
the sell price seems to be about 135 and
999. So we'll pop the gold leaves in for
135 998.
35 998.
And
yeah, looks good to me.
Moving on to the magic stone.
Magic stone
seems to sell for about 999k
at the current price. So we'll go ahead
and pop those in there. We will
sell these for 998k. Good.
And last up, the marble blocks.
We have the day graph open here. And it
seems to sell for 333k.
So we'll go ahead, pop these in here for
and
800.
Okay, so we'll go ahead, sell all these
off, and we'll come back when they have
sold.
All right, guys. So, everything has
Uh the gold leaves only took like an
hour. Marble blocks, a bit longer, and
magic stones even longer, but not too
long, and uh we sold them without any
problems. So, we'll go ahead and collect
all the money.
And uh we'll see how much we actually
made in total. So, we're back up to 35
mil, which is a good sign. I'll pop into
the price check, and we made 946k.
That is insane. That was only 10 minutes
of work. Not too bad.
Um so, I hope you guys enjoyed the the
method. Uh definitely go give it a try.
It's definitely the easiest money I've
ever made,
and uh I will see you guys in the next
video.
[Music]